by this point the odds are pretty good
that you've already heard about the slab
heard around the world of course just in
case you somehow managed to avoid the
absolute deluge of headlines related to
this incident a quick recap is an order
during the 94th annual academy awards
ceremony comedian chris rock told a joke
that seemed to irk actress jada pinkett
smith only moments later pinkett smith's
husband the fresh prince himself will
smith approached rock on the stage and
slapped him across the face before
returning to a sea to shout obscenities
at a clearly shaken rock despite the
awkward attack and plenty of speculation
about the incident on social media the
night ultimately continued on as planned
indeed before the night was even over
smith was actually invited back up to
the stage to accept the 2022 academy
award for best actor in a leading role
in his subsequent speech smith made
numerous references to working as a
defender of his family notably smith
also appeared to draw parallels between
his actions and those of the man he
played in king richard the real-life
father of serena and venus williams
needless to say smith's actions and his
speech have been the subject of a great
deal of controversy however this
actually isn't the first time smith has
been associated with a slap across the
face long before slap gates there was
another less known incident if you ever
get invited to will smith's birthday
party be careful you may find yourself
getting a present of your own in the
form of a pop in the jaw from the guy
who played muhammad ali in one of his
five best performances at least that
might happen to you if you're anthony
maki the foul connector told his story
about getting accidentally bunched in
the face during the 2021 appearance on
siriusxm suggest kegel show to promote
his netflix movie titled outside the
wire according to mackie outside the
wire was actually shot in budapest
hungary a city that often serves as a
home filming site for a number of
different international productions at
the same time that maki was in budapest
on work smith was also nearby shooting
his own science fiction movie
paramount's gemini man during the shoot
smith celebrated his 50th birthday in
the city and mackie got his very own
special invitation to the party in
preparation for the event mackie's
publicist asked him if he wanted to be
the one to present smith with his
birthday cake of course mackie responded
affirmatively unfortunately that was
where the actor's mistakes began mackie
recalled i'm on stage with will smith
doing a concert
i'm losing my mind right so the cake
comes out we bring the cake out will
smith sees me and he goes hey anthony
mackie i'm like will smith there's my
name the hilarious story continues when
mackie explains so i go to like high
five i don't know what i was trying to
do but like i was trying to hug him and
he thought i was coming in for like a
high five so he like tried to grab my
arm and he punched me in the jaw so hard
mackie ends the story and clearly it was
a good-natured comedy of varys he hit me
with a right cross
so hard then he grabbed me and he's like
you good i was like i think so
of course smith and mackie were quick to
recover and confirmed with each other
that everything was alright stars
they're just like us having really
awkward moments with the people they
want to impress host jess kagor noted
that will smith learned a punch from
muhammad ali himself so maki had better
be careful he concluded his story by
saying
yo he has a right cross man protect
yourself cause dude came in i mean woo
it was a punch but i took a punch from
muhammad ali i can say it maki's own
punching can be seen in the sci-fi
action film outside the wire which is
available for streaming on netflix
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movie stars are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]